Hello everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters and in this video in this section of our website, we're going to talk about gastrointestinal cancers.
Now your GI system really starts in the mouth and ends where you deposit feces in the toilet, but in this section, we're really going to talk about the cancers from your stomach down.
Now your GI cancers are named after the area that the cancer has found and the cell type that the cancer has found.
It's important to understand when we're talking about any cancer.
If I have rectal cancer and it metastasizes to my liver, it's not liver cancer. Now it's still rectal cancer that's metastasized to my liver.
So it's still those cells that cell type of the original spot, that origin of the cancer that is metastasized.
So liver cancer is cancer of the liver cells. Rectal cancer or another cancer is cancer of those other cells that may metastasize to a different area.
So we can have metastasized cancer to the GI tract. Then it's not primary. It's secondary. It's metastasized cancer.
So in this section, we're talking about primary GI cancers of the stomach on down.
So those are named after the cell type that is found in the biopsy and named after the area of where the primary cancer was found.
Whether it's small intestine, gastric cancer, anal cancer, appendiceal cancer and so on.
Now it can be very difficult when you get a diagnosis of any type of cancer on deciding what to do. Many people are hurting down a pathway that quite frankly they may regret down the road.
My recommendation for everybody, when you get a diagnosis of cancer, it's very scary. I know I've been there.
But when you get a diagnosis of cancer, the best thing to do is to slow down. Don't make any rash judgments and grave decisions that you may want to.
There's nothing you can do to change if you go into surgery. It's done. You can't undo that.
So you can always do surgery. You can always do chemo. You can always do radiation. But you always have more time than usually than what you're told.
Not that you're supposed to stick your head on the sand and pretend it's not there, but slow down. Take a little time. Do some research.
It's also important to understand that when you're considering chemo radiation, surgery or whatever else that you can't also do alternative care at the same time.
And quite frankly, that's probably going to be your best bet to help improve the outcome. I'm not against doing chemo radiation, surgery or immunotherapy or something combination thereof.
If it's the right thing for you, but I think it's probably kind of silly not to make some dietary changes and look at nutrition and look at other therapeutic interventions, aka alternative care, that would be wise to help you, even if you do choose to do chemo or radiation or something, it'll help you get through that much better.
So that's all I'm asking you to do it. And really, that's what our whole website is all about. And that's why we give away my books on this site too.
So navigate to the free books. Download them. They're free. Not everybody's ever going to be able to come to us, but we feel like we want this clinic to be as much of a ministry as possible so that you can gain knowledge.
We are called by God to not be foolish and not be ignorant. And of course, that's talking about scriptural things, but it's also talking about how we live our lives or the decisions that we're making that that change in all through our life.
So adding alternative care to standards of care or doing alternative care prior to doing standards of care. So maybe that you won't need to do that.
Standard of care that they're recommending at least look into it. That's what this is all about. And when you do look into it, I know it is confusing.
Should I take, you know, this supplement or that supplement or eat this food or use this type of therapy? Well, please use this in this website as best you can to gain as much knowledge as you can.
And if you do feel led to schedule a case review with me so that we can talk about it.
Ultimately, we want you to have the best results possible, the best outcome possible from this diagnosis. And that's really what our goal is for you.
So utilize this site, utilize our free material and please be blessed by it. We're always here for you.